[Musique]
2020 pour nous c'est l'année de la
reconquête la reconquête par le débat
d'idées comme nous l'avons fait sur les
retraites sur les autres sujets nous
serons présents dans le débat d'idées
l'année de la reconquête électorale avec
les municipales donc cette année 2020
est une année essentielle pour nous je
vous souhaite pour l'année 2020 pour
l'année qui vient
beaucoup de prospérité beaucoup de
joueurs et je vous souhaite que la
france redevienne le pays de l'ordre
juste de l'ordre pour que l'autorité de
l'état soit rétablie partout et pour
tous de la justice parce que l'idéal de
justice sociale doit s'épanouir et la
récompense du travail et de l'effort la
re devenir la norme est la règle vous
pouvez compter sur tous les républicains
sur christian jacob sur aurélien pradié
et sur toute l'équipe dirigeante pour
mieux encore vous défendre et vous
représentez pour 2020 chacun de nos
concitoyens doit trouver sa place dans
notre pays nous souhaitons pour cette
nouvelle année que la france redevienne
une france qui laisse une place à chaque
française et à chaque français la droite
c'est le courage et la justice pour les
républicains 2020 sera cette année
du courage politique et cette année de
la justice nous voulons un pays dans
lequel nous sommes capables de réformer
mais nous voulons aussi un pays dans
lequel nous sommes capables de porter
des mesures justes pour chacun de nos
concitoyens
voilà le voeu que je formule pour cette
nouvelle année 2020 alors 2020 c'est
l'année où les républicains vont
retrouver le chemin du rassemblement de
la victoire et vont retrouver le coeur
des français 2020 sera l'année des
territoires avec d'autres belle victoire
pour les républicains aux municipales
2020 sera l'année du débat d idées 2020
sera l'année de la jeunesse avec la
grande université de rentrée des jeunes
républicains qui permettra de remettre
les jeunes de droite au coeur de notre
projet 2020 pour les républicains sera
l'année de l'humilité de l'action
savoir se retrousser les manches pour
aller reconquérir le coeur des français
savoir laisser la place à toutes celles
et ceux qui souhaitent s'investir dans
notre famille politique 2020 ce sera
l'année de la réconcilier
des français et pour les républicains la
victoire pour les municipales vous
l'avez compris 2020 est un enjeu
essentiel pour nous ça doit être une
bonne année et j'en profite au nom des
républicains pour vous souhaiter à tous
et à toutes une très bonne année 2020 et
croyez moi nous nous serons au rendez
vous
[Musique]